this is tom cruise really taking off of
an aircraft carrier he's adding
something that is incredibly valuable by
him putting himself at this much risk
what
so this right here is simon crane
ziplining from one airplane to another
it's crazy hiding back
what's up everybody welcome back to
stuntman react we got eric with us today
thank you for having me you are the true
og you started this whole series eric
obviously appreciate everybody uh all
the love and telling me what we could
react to and stuff like that so we
really want to focus on some things you
guys maybe didn't think of or bigger
grandiose stunts sweet heck yeah
let's get into it
yeah so this clip right here give you a
little setup we're taking a look at
hooper
it is based on the life of a stuntman
this is a huge car chase sequence at the
end
of the movie that they're making it's
like the big finale
hell yeah runaway oil container
dude i miss real explosions man
everybody just has them in cg now yeah
you can tell fire is one of the most
beautiful things on film
is that thing coming down
oh it is getting get it get it drive
under drive under it
wow dude these things are just a simple
split screen effect but back then
nope go for it my life's worth more than
a piece of film
i'll tell you exactly what your life is
worth your life is worth 50 000 that's
the price you put on it when you got
behind this
wheel i'm gonna hit it
[Applause]
what
what
you know this is just a great sum up of
like kind of what a stunt person is
going through especially when it comes
to doing a big gag like pipe ramping a
car uh setting yourself on fire and
that's why it gets a little bit
frustrating when like you're trying to
come up with a budget as a stunt
coordinator you know the danger level is
pretty high you're letting a guy on fire
and you're like well i'm going to give
them a 3 000 adjustment and they're like
whoa what what why what i mean don't
they like getting lit on fire
you're like
look pal so you constantly have this
fight again and again and again trying
to tell them what uh essentially a human
life is worth if something goes wrong at
some point i'm sure you know you get
injured and you have to like balance out
all the paychecks you're getting for
when you're in work for like when the
times happen where you're injured and
you can't be in work you know yeah
absolutely for example i think i got
let's call it like 1500 bucks to jump
out the window on punisher well i broke
my ankle oh damn and had to re-learn how
to walk you know so this guy's putting
50 gs on his life to where he may not
make it across the bridge
what's the most expensive stunt
adjustment that you know of on
cliffhanger the sly stallone movie the
stuntman was paid one million dollars
what transfer from one plane to another
plane um on a zip line i think we need
to check this out
[Music]
what the hell is he doing
so this right here is simon crane
zip lining from one airplane to another
is that his reel like that's it right it
would be mine it'd just be like i did
this yeah it's like all right
we got to get this guy yeah he's got
parachute on underneath in case
something goes wrong and he needs to he
needs to bail or unclip
but just as he reaches the door a pocket
of powerful turbulence blasts him off
course
he's crazy hiding back i hope there's a
really nice dinner for him in the
airplane oh what
that's where he made the million dollars
yeah see he didn't even make it in the
door i got thrown to the side and as
soon as i was clear of the plane i could
release myself my parachute down
damn that's crazy it's crazy that he
didn't get into the actual airplane it
was like just getting slung around on
the top of it most productions wouldn't
let you do this but if you're either a
tom cruise or if you're christopher
nolan i bet he's like yo i want that
they're doing it that's legit i could
see that that's insane like okay i get
it now like yeah a million dollars
that's so risky
what do you spin the mill on dude
diapers man
clean underwear yeah yeah we are only a
mere 570 000 subscribers away from
hitting 5 million
so definitely take part in helping us
get there hit the subscribe button it's
a small effort on your part that does a
great service to us so thank you so much
for watching speaking of tom cruise i
know that i know you're amped for top
gun super i know you're super
i'm super amped for top gun and that
trailer blew me away
look at that dude i cannot get out of
here dude
imax i want i want to lose my hearing at
the end of this movie like
there's one point in this trailer
there's just one moment where he takes
off of the aircraft carrier or he goes
like
it's
yes tom cruise has been a pilot for
quite some time this is tom cruise
really taking off of an aircraft carrier
and you can tell because that look at
the the g-forces pushing on his face i
would assume like there's no way they're
gonna let tom cruise go off on his own
there's there's gotta be a guy in there
just to make sure everything's going
okay in case something messes up
definitely they'll take over i'm saying
certainly there's somebody else in the
plane uh there for safety but he's
pulling this off himself yeah i know 100
in your opinion you know how does
something like like this with tom cruise
play out like do you feel like he's
putting everybody's job at risk when
he's doing a stunt or do you think it's
something that just makes these movies
special and that's what they got to have
is to have tom cruise doing the stunt
it's both really i mean he's adding
something that is uh incredibly valuable
by him putting himself at this much risk
i mean you're getting just stuff on film
that is amazing and that you can't pull
off tom's certainly producing all of his
own movies now with his own production
company but that's why he's able to do
this stuff is because he makes the rules
he's like i'm doing this but he also is
putting everybody's job at risk as well
i'd imagine that their insurance has
something built in yeah because when he
broke his leg uh that shut down the
production for x amount of months for
him to be able to heal and they probably
put the crew on some sort of severance
package or something you guys know tom
cruise is going to space right that's
what i heard the first actor to go to
space and film a movie in space i'm like
unless he's from space
he might be hey he might be so this is a
clip i've been wanting to show you
forever this is like an example of
awesome wirework just just check it out
is that lucy lou yeah
wow
little explosion wait a minute but
there's this shot's like wow they're
falling oh
oh
that's the one good moment in this
entire movie
that was awesome yeah actually i know
that's how the shot was done it's a full
rig right yeah there's a camera you know
it's like the arm
that this is going as fast as we're
seeing it eric knows exactly what's
going on oh really
yeah he's the pro he
i saw the behind the scenes but eric
just like nailed it so basically this
whole rig we got a guy like this here's
the camera four points going down to the
guy so they're moving in unison all the
way down and when they get to
the impact of the car just before he
hits it they have something that's
attached to the roof that then goes punk
and pulls it down and then some more
explosives that blow the windows out
i've never heard of anything that
collapses a car like that from it
reverse pulls it down that's what they
did in the hood of the car and uh the
matrix reloaded when the agent jumps off
of it oh yeah like that yeah they have
an inverse hydraulic ram
yeah kind of like when they do uh like
pipe ramps which also we could take a
look at the james bond casino royale
flip they broke a record for seven flips
of the car
basically that that piston is in this
inside the bottom of the car and then it
fires it down into the ground which then
launches the car up in the air this is
that in reverse where it's extended and
then sucks it into the piston dude this
is this is cool this is i've never seen
this before this is very special great
clip dude yeah hey guys a lot of these
clips that we see in the show are
inspired from the things that you found
so i have requests for you for stunts
here please leave a suggestion down
below of the coolest stunt from a
foreign film that you have seen that way
we can look for some clips here that
might be
unseen by a lot of our audience and shed
some light on how they're made
that crazy guy right there with the
white hair looks like a complete psycho
is uh dar robinson i mean he is a
legendary stunt man a pioneer in the
field this is the shot right here oh
true that's some anger right there yeah
dude that's awesome see no airbag down
there this was one of or the very first
descender
so he's on wires there and i don't think
that they can wipe wires then so he is
on
like a monofilament type of
very very thin wire you can kind of see
it pull him a little bit there at the
end man so a descender uh for this
particular
stunt there you're on a line but you are
jumping into freefall you know you may
free fall for 30 feet and then the
descender starts kicking in and and it
kind of decelerates your uh free fall
you you stop falling without whipping
against the line or hitting the ground
this is like soft breaks
exactly he's got disc brakes on that one
yeah you know this is one of the the
first of its kind now like for example
you would use a winch and now it's all
computerized so it'll wind it up really
fast and it'll pull the rope up so you
may take off and then it'll unwind and
set you down you know you wouldn't
necessarily need something like that
anymore
dude eric that was awesome man it is
always a pleasure having you on the show
thanks for having me back like i
hopefully we brought some stuff that's
interesting to you guys and i felt like
we all got a kick out of it yeah dude
thanks for coming back man also by the
way uh if you're wondering how to get
into stunts i got that question so many
times i actually put up an entire page
on my website uh it's at
ericlinden.com
stunts so definitely hit up eric and
check out that faq sheet he put together
he spent a lot of time doing it and just
breaks down a lot of questions that you
guys already have um but eric thanks
again for coming on dude i freaking love
you man it's so good to see you awesome
good to see you guys